organizaciones terroristas así declaró
israel a seis grandes ong de derechos
humanos palestinas obligándolas a cerrar
sus oficinas cesar sus labores y
autorizando los funcionarios israelíes a
confiscar y arrestar a sus miembros bajo
la acusación de canalizar las donaciones
para promocionar a grupos militantes
palestinos
aj más la decisión se tomó sobre una
base fáctica y jurídica después de que
este asunto fuera examinado en el
ministerio de justicia y en este sentido
se apoya en una base sólida en el doctor
peter y está natural la medida israelí
fue recibida con indignación entre los
grupos dedicados entre otras funciones a
la documentación de presuntas
violaciones de derechos de israel contra
los sitiados territorios palestinos
si se trata claramente de una decisión
política y de la continuación de la
campaña israelí que se lleva a cabo
desde hace décadas dirigida a las
organizaciones palestinas con el
objetivo de silenciar las y atemorizar
las para impedirles desempeñar su papel
en defensa de los derechos humanos de
los palestinos de fifa google es el
fortín y en un comunicado conjunto human
rigth watch y amnistía internacional
también criticaron la injusta decisión
el sábado las autoridades palestinas
mostraron su rechazo señalando un ataque
estratégico contra la sociedad civil
palestina
hacemos un llamado al mundo para ayudar
a detener esta decisión que es contraria
a las leyes internacionales todos estos
grupos están registrados son legales y
reciben fondos internacionales
de daule guayas erakat alamillo para los
defensores de derechos se trata de un
silenciamiento que puede derivar en
mayores abusos de las fuerzas israelíes
contra los palestinos